blimey this sat nav's taking us down
some back roads isn't it yes it's almost
like I'm taking you down a back road
that sounds rude it does it's almost
like we're doing a route trip we're
driving from frats bottom to balls cross
the question is why because I thought it
was funny because it's funny really yeah
because we're children along the way we
both picked out a couple of locations we
haven't told the other what those
locations are uh we can drive there
you're gonna watch or or don't we it
doesn't matter just just stay here watch
it I don't know do we care
okay to start I'll drive first I've got
somewhere I want to take all right
do I need to make the car noises I mean
the car's gonna do that itself it's it's
a car it is a hybrid you know I didn't
get uh didn't get a sports car or
anything for you but oh
I might make them anyway I mean feel
free I did no research by the way I have
absolutely no idea why it's called traps
bottom no we didn't talk to anyone there
to see if they find it funny we just
we're just there to abuse ourselves yes
it's just just for us so we should
explain how this works uh I picked the
start and end points I picked uh Pratt's
bottom and balls cross uh and then I
sent the route to Matt and we've both
picked a couple of locations on the way
uh and you'll see the ones that are
vaguely entertaining
and we haven't told each other where
we're going so Matt's starting off
because he's taking somewhere yep later
on it'll be me
um I said we should tell you how that
works that was just a monologue from me
really yeah it was but I am also trying
to navigate to a roundabout and work out
where we're going
the thing that I want to note really is
that I I fully understand that the one
thing that the internet needs right now
is that it hasn't got enough of is two
white men making toilet jokes yeah
so we're going to balls cross
the one piece of advice I have for you
is don't cross your balls at Ball's
cross that's called testicular torsion
and I wouldn't recommend it I've had it
before you know have you I wouldn't
recommend it at all no it's also a good
name for a death metal band but you know
hello we're testicular torches
it's the sound you make when you've got
it yes it's actually quite painful
I thought he'd take you somewhere there
was something something you'd like to
look at all right
I think this is going to be right up
your street streets hey
I'm quite glad it's you doing this
section Matt
you are much more confident in the tight
Corners than I would be
I think I think I'd have scratched the
car back there going through that type
bit that's growing up in the country sir
not my name on the waiver
thanks Tom
let's not hit the cycle how many points
to hit a cyclist or or the oncoming car
I appreciate that you had a passing
flight today yeah um but you went past
the cyclists and just bullied Your Way
Forward
[Music]
speed limit
the thing is we didn't move any faster
during that rev the car made zero
velocity change you just
it's like the advantages of a rental
well when it said it was hybrid I
thought we'd get at least some of the um
from the electric the instant talk but
no it means it means it's just got a big
heavy battery in the back just in case
I've put a Lamborghini on my rider
you wouldn't fit
I've tried I actually I tried getting in
a hurricane once and
that was the loudest ring because we got
signal again if you could pull into the
next lay-by we're gonna jump ahead so I
think we're nearly there all right
I mean this is somewhere you don't know
either right no I've never been here
before I was looking on the map
it's a taxi viewpoint
thank you to the tetsy foundation
do you like the sound of a titsy
Viewpoint I do like the sounds
[Music]
so it says titsy Viewpoint is just up
there yeah that's the plan not that I've
ever been here before the titsy
foundation guided walks I mean we don't
no really sign here I think the titsy
foundation walk you have a choice of two
different length walks either four miles
or two miles no it is 32 degrees today
that is not happening lunch lunch
welcome to titsy
it's not like we needed to stay for
anything other than the net no no it's
not worth going to the Viewpoint that's
uh that's far too hot and far too long
in this weather so where we're going for
lunch okay which was also your call
yeah yeah we get to stay though because
it's lunch that's our lunch works you
have lunch there yeah yeah you do for
those of you who don't know how lunch
works you have lunch
[Laughter]
I have no way of answering this phone
call
oh my God oh my God that's so loud
so loud so loud I appreciate though the
thought of picking Tipsy Viewpoint I
just assumed that was going to be like a
beautiful view over the whole world
too much effort disappointing car park
with with a very long walk
that's a good Viaduct
that's very nice
can we get your phone out get a shot of
them yeah I'll get a shot of that
Viaduct
that's a good Viaduct that is that's a
very good Viaduct
a plus five well no it's maybe a B plus
Viaduct I've seen better viaducts I like
that it's iron
Tipsy sounds like the name of someone
from like a Noir detective film
she told me
how do you like my Noir detective accent
it's the same as every other accent you
do
[Laughter]
go on give us French oh titty yes
je m'appelle
jackass Lane hey
oh we should have got a picture there
well we could help the traffic jam with
some jokes
we could
what's stickier makes a weird noise my
brakes
okay we're driving Tom yeah that means
we should play I Spy but as we know I
suppose quite a boring game yeah so we
can go for a slightly different version
of it the person who first lays eyes on
a pie wins
first Lay's Eyes On Ice spot I spy your
eyes buying a pie eyes pie eyes eyes pie
might be a while before we see a pie
yeah okay
well I'm not even sure if where we go
for lunch we'll we'll have the pie but
okay
so loud
just the right amount of time passed for
us to forget
right how are you guys getting on
um a minute
that's a lovely little village yeah
Headley tea rooms I thought I'd take it
for lunch that's very nice
another [ __ ] in
okay yep yep
there's a pattern in the places you've
chosen Matt
I was like choose some interesting
things to do we go are you saying I'm a
child
I'm saying there's a pattern you know
are we gonna have to eat sausage or
something
absolutely not I haven't even done any
driving yet oh no you haven't
I was going to say which table do you
want but should we go to the one that
the cameras are pointing at yeah
Tipsy viewpoint a bit of a bust
that's funny because spoke words mean
boobs I didn't expect that online quite
as well as it did but I'll take it I
don't think anyone wants to watch us eat
lunch uh so while we're doing that
here's the sponsor thanks for lunch I
keep endorsing nordvpn because they keep
being genuinely useful for me as you
might have noticed I've been traveling a
lot lately and it turns out some U.S
sites block visitors from Europe
entirely because they can't be bothered
to comply with the Privacy regulations
here now with a couple of clicks on
nordvpn's app on my laptop or phone
they're available again I'm sure you can
think of some other things you'd like to
access from your country although do
check their terms of service first and
plus right now I'm in southern
Switzerland so websites keep being all
like
sometimes there's not even an option to
change that back but I turn on nordvpn
and the problem's fixed I'm actually
using them regularly I'm kind of
surprised too nordvpn Works across
Windows Mac Linux IOS and Android you
can have six devices connected at a time
and if it's not for you that's okay they
have a 30-day money-back guarantee if
you go to nordvpn.com
you'll find the best deal they're
currently offering whenever you're
watching this
right with all that said back to the
show that was a good lunch yeah
yeah it's my choice
where we're going next because that's
the whole point that's the whole point
of this I will say it's not just a silly
night we are yes you said that actively
actually going to somewhere that is um
content I guess it's a better word it's
something I don't think either of us
have done before but it's not a silly
name cool it's not even not just a silly
name it's not a silly name not a city
not a silly name see the thing is I I
know now that at some point in the next
few minutes the crew in the Chase car
I got a ring us oh crap yes
at some point this is gonna go blink
really loudly and we're both going to
startle and we're going to have
forgotten yep because the best comic
timing we're getting all day every
single time is is chekhov's phone oh
there is no power in this yeah see what
I mean I really need to put my foot down
there
absolutely nothing happened it didn't
even make a noise that time
hey Siri
type to my voice hey Siri
that is a terrible impression on me but
I think it's actually tied to like the
formant of your voice so George
Foreman's Grill yeah yeah oh yes yep big
[ __ ] at the roundabout there we go
you know I've had uh go around my head
is it the vengabus oh no it isn't the
venga bus
oh
the name of Hamilton they don't Hamilton
they don't sing the name his name enough
in the song but it's been going around
my head a lot
can I do the entirety of Alexander
Hamilton and guns and ships yes I can am
I able to do that on camera for a
YouTube thing no absolutely not
another
excuse my French
wow wow every time every time
I put my phone has been seen and
appreciated and filmed
that's what she said
Super Bowl does that mean they've got
the American Football World
Championships here no no to to reuse no
joke it is just a load of superb owls
obviously go and see some superb battles
I would love to see some super battles
all right
you know you get an owl Sanctuary yeah
the phrase lamb shanks Fury
it's Sanctuary they just fly up and they
shave you
[Laughter]
welcome to a garden center a garden
center Garden Center
actually
we're coming just here
because you know when you said Super
Bowl yes and I was like superb owl and
you were like oh I'd like to see some
superb owls are we are we actually going
to see some super Bells hello guys
you're right welcome thank you very much
we've actually got some Mounds for you
oh amazing thank you I cannot believe we
made that gag yeah it was perfect
so we've got Sorrel or horny out here
hello and this is one of our uh that we
have in the UK
so what I'm going to do is just time on
here okay so that way if he tries to fly
off it just takes you with him
[Laughter]
there you go if you turn your glove that
way for me awesome put them on there
what's his name his name's Sorrel Sorrel
hello are you gonna look at me in the
face hey hello you've got big eyes
why are you cute I normally don't find
animals cute it's good that I'm finding
it cute
oh hello
[Music]
hello sorrow
I am holding an owl
this is something I should have like
ticked off my list a long time ago
because yeah you can you can go meet an
hour and the funny thing is as a
millennial the first thing I think is
our selfie but we don't need our selfie
because we have two cameras
that's always just rebalancing
that way so
hey
there we go
hello take it back and I'll get
something else for you oh wow this is
Loki is our Eurasian eagle out Loki he's
just over it yeah Loki he's the favorite
year old
being the Eurasian these are the largest
of these house yep okay behold your arm
nice and steady yep no tip have you bend
your elbow yeah you won't use all those
things yeah and you'll relax hello
wow
I I can't tell if you have an in-depth
conversation or if or if he thinks he's
being locked oh that is I'm nervous
yes hello
hello
I think because he's pointing that way
now rather than at me yeah that is an
owl staring down the camera lens
that's fun something special oh you are
beautiful oh thanks what about that hey
I'll let you have a go first because
you're the bird person this is a
peregrine falcon oh
I have only ever seen these from a very
very long distance what's his name uh
Hades Hades of course
oh yeah boy oh hello
I'm that's it's never occurred to me
that peregrine falcons have a call Tom I
think you need a photo of this
I got a terrible photo of you with the
uh owl earlier
I mean I'm gonna get the same photo here
it's just
there we go
hi
we're in consensus for you
can
this feels like a stupid question but
that's what I'm here for
so dogs and cats can come when you call
their name can birds I assume that they
can't well to a point
um I'm not sure whether they understand
a name per se so what we do when we're
naming our Birds we find someone with
two syllables so they get used to the
sounds yes as opposed to her name is
self I love how we've had a little
wholesome interlude yes because if we
started it where did we start uh rats we
start at Pratt's bottom yeah we've gone
to titsy we've gone to the [ __ ] in and
then we've had a wholesome bird
interlude I feel like this says
something about our personalities but
it's mostly just that I I want to meet
you like birds I want to meet now and
I've got to meet an owl another owl and
a falcon so I'm happy there is there is
one destination left to finish the rope
and I think that's Bull's cross it is
shall we go
oh man now I'm happy with that yeah
thank you for that that is something I
would never have chosen to do myself
that's what I was hoping I enjoyed it
good and the first one was cute the
other two were scary
quite scary yep
so our last stop is our destination
balls cross balls cross
now the one thing that a road trip needs
yeah is music yeah we don't have a
license for any no we don't
but uh-huh I have access to the same
stock music company that you use oh yeah
and I've put together a driving playlist
of stock music amazing do you have like
epic road trip ending finale music I
don't know but I can find some
at this point that's just dangerous the
music can wait
hi hello
the music we need is like
soaring uh anthemic uh hopeful this is
the top results for epic finale all
right uh that'll do that's that's
Montage Music that is
yeah this is doing it
I don't feel like we deserve it we're
driving past an unfinished little and
we're going to a place called balls
cross
but you know what the sun's coming down
job done I'll take it
so through the hill and roundabout we go
on to the a29 henceforth we shall arrive
at the cross of balls
balls across
you know I might be overregging it a bit
I think you might be over egging your
balls and no one wants over eggs balls
it's one of those things where you tell
someone you're doing this you go are you
gonna make a video out of that but with
somehow find some content you're still
watching yeah
it's got a sign
all right hazards on can we park here we
can oh yeah yeah
oh there's a ditch don't go any further
okay
okay yeah that's good that's good there
we go we got it right how's it done it
is nothing into Park
[Music]
[Music]
this shouldn't be funny
there's Nettles here this was a bad idea
good night everybody we made it to Bulls
cross
don't copy it we're not setting an
example
what should we do now go on
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
you're driving all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]